네, 안녕하세요. 뉴스 브리핑
시작하겠습니다. 우선 첫 번째로 올해
9월까지 빌딩 및 토지 거래량이
전국의 [음악] 57조가 팔렸는데
그중에 1위가 서울이라고 합니다.
서울이 약 한 50% 정도 차지하는
거 같아요. 거래 가액이 굉장히
컸다라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
일단 또 세부적으로 좀 들어가서
보면은 강남구가 제일 높아요. 거래
금액이 제일 높습니다. 근데 건수로만
봤을 때는 종로나 뭐 용상구 이쪽이
많아요. 근데 여기 세부적으로 좀
들어가 보면 이렇게 되게 작은 것들
이렇게 쪼개서 파는 아니면 이제
재개발을 통해서 매각하는 건수도
굉장히 많기 때문에 어 실질적으로
지금 거래 금액도 그렇지만 1위는
강남구라고 보시면 될 거 같아요.
제가 항상 빌딩 투자할 때
말씀드리는게 잘 팔리는 곳에 매입을
해야 된다라고 좀 말씀을 드리는데 어
이런 데이터들은 좀 유심히 보시면
좋을 거 같아요. 그래서 더
나아가서는 동별로 잘 팔리는 지역을
보시면 좋을 것 같습니다. 빌딩은
무조건 황금성이에요. 뭐 수익률 이런
거 다 떠나서 [음악] 이렇게 안
팔리는 지역의 건물을 매입하면은
건물이 안 팔립니다. 그래서 어떤
지역이 거래가 좀 많이 되는지를
보시면 좋을 거 같아요. 네.
그다음에 상업용 부동산 상승세
꺾였다. 회복세는 지속. 이게 지금
기사를 보면은 아무래도 사이즈가 좀
큰 빌딩 기준이거든요. 거의 프라임급
빌딩들 거래량이 좀 줄어들었다라고
보시면 되는데 요게 어떤 기준으로
했는지가 자세히 안 나와 있네요.
근데 제가 봤을 때는 타이틀만 보면
좀 그런게 있지만 자세한 내용으로
들어가면 어 이런 큰 빌딩 기준이라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 그리고 이제
뭐 연예인 빌딩들도 좀 보면은 뭐
조인성 경리단길 [음악]
건물 가치 74억 원 13년 만에
44억 원 상승 이렇게 돼 있는데
12년도에 30억 5천에 매입을 했고
어 여기 뭐 직접 카페도 좀 운영했던
걸로 알고 있어요. 근데 13년
치고는 가격이 많이 오르진
않았습니다. 그때 30억이면 굉장히
큰 돈이었고 다른 지역에 매입했으면
아마 더 많이 올랐을 거예요. 근데
경리단끼이 좀 많이 안 좋아지면서
이렇게 시세 차액이 나중에 뭐 그렇게
클 거 같진 않은데 근데 이것도 이제
중계 업체 좀 홍보하려고 기사를 좀
냈던 거죠. 그리고 조인성 씨가 전에
역삼동의 예전 르네상스 호텔
사거리죠. 지금 센터필드 있는
[음악] 그 사거리의 건물을 되게
싸게 팔았어요. 거의 원가에
팔았거든요. 거기 지금 광고판도
달리고 통임대도 들어오고 지금 패스트
파이브 들어가 있는데 너무 빨리
팔았어요. 아마 곧 광고판 수익만
해도 꽤 클 거 같았는데 그것도 너무
싸게 팔고 그렇습니다. 네. 그리고
이제 다음 기사 보면은 60억이
600억으로 강남 빌딩 투자로 재파
터트린 국민 배우 그 박중훈 씨가
나옵니다. [음악] 그래서 그
역삼동에 한 4층 정도 되는 건물을
되게 오래 전에 샀었어요. 20여년
전에 한 60억 원에 사 가지고 이게
리모델링을 거치는게 아니라 신축을
했어요. 어, 여기가 상업지다 보니까
건물을 굉장히 좀 높게 올렸습니다.
지금 시세가 뭐 600억 정도
된다라는 기사입니다. 그때 당시에
굉장히 잘 사 가지고 건물을 올려서
지금 뭐 임대 수익도 굉장히 좀 잘
나오는 건물이고 대표적인 좀 성공
사례인 거 같아요. 네. 그래서 조금
정리해 볼게요. 그래서 올해 뭐 빌딩
거래량이 좀 많이 늘어났고 그중에
서울시가 주로 매각이 됐다라는 기사
봤었고데 그중에 강남구가 거래
금액으로 봤을 때는 제일 높다라고
보시면 될 거 같고 그리고 저는 계속
말씀드리지만 벨팅 투자할 때 잘
팔리는 동네 그리고 그 동네에 어느
정도 금액대가 제일 거래가 많이
되는지를 우선적으로 봐야 되고 그리고
뭐 상업용 부동산 상승세 꺾였다 뭐
이런 기사가 있는데 실제로 들어가서
보면은 우리가 생각하는 그 정도의
꼬마 빌딩이 아니라 거의 프라임급
빌딩 기준으로 으로 어 이렇게 기사를
쓴 거 같습니다. 그리고 조인성
[음악] 씨 경리단길 빌딩이 뭐
74억이다. 많이 오르진 않았다.
네. 13년 치고는 많이 오르지
않았다. 뭐 이렇게 저는 생각을
합니다. 그리고 60억에 박중훈 씨가
건물을 사 가지고 건물을 지은 다음에
지금 600억 정도의 건물로 됐다라는
내용인데 이것도 매입되는 4층짜리의
되게 낡은 건물이었지만 일반 상업
지역이다 보니까 용적률을 거의
800%까지 받아서 건물을 이렇게
많이 높게 올린 다음에 좀 수익을
극대화한 그런 사례라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 그래서 오늘 좀 이렇게
뉴스 간단하게 좀 설명을 드렸고 매주
제가 좀 이렇게 빌딩과 관련된 아니면
여러분들한테 좀 도움이 될 만한
뉴스를 계속 준비할 예정이니까
여러분들 관심 갖고 봐 주시면
감사하겠습니다. 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다. 감사합니다.